[Music]
has been in the business since age 11
and now Miley is opening up about the
demands that come with being a child
star that's a lot to put on the kids to
have them have to go get their makeup
done and then also balance school and
then also have me dress up you know in a
wig as a kid is a little weird you know
it's a little toddlers in tiaras I think
the harder when I started touring as
both I toured as Hannah Montana and as
myself I think that's probably was a
little bit wrong with me now I marked
that up to doing some extreme damage and
my psyche as an adult person even so
Miley tells CBS Sunday morning her child
star life never felt strange growing up
on her family's 500 acre farm she could
always turn to her dad Billy Ray Cyrus
and her godmother
don't leave partner it felt so normal
cuz my dad Dolly Parton died is it's
like yeah you get up you go have
breakfast with my dad and then you go
play a show for 20,000 people that's
normal that's probably also what's wrong
with me his therapy we're figuring out
what's wrong
[Music]
since those early years Miley's taking a
wrecking ball to Hannah Montana's
wholesome image and thinks other stars
should thank everyone you're welcome I
took all the slaps for you everything
that anyone could have been mad at I've
done it all so nothing seems that bad
compared to all the things I've done I
have a quote in my place where I do yoga
and it says the more that you love your
own decisions the less you need other
people to love them yes Miley use the
difficulties in your life you learn from
them and you propel forward good for you
[Music]